[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning we are
getting an
exclusive first look at a new report
detailing how americans
lost even more money in 2020 to fake
sweepstakes and prize and lottery scams
than they did the year before so
americans had about 227 million dollars
stolen from them last year that is a 33
percent increase
from 2019. our consumer investigative
correspondent anna werner got a look at
the report and reveals what red flags to
watch out for
and if people like to win but in these
cases i guess they're not good morning
to you
yeah good morning tony you know the
interesting thing is the bbb says the
number of complaints
actually went down last year but the
amount of money lost
went way up and families like the one
you're about to meet
are the victims i never would have
thought
my dad would be susceptible or
this it really shocked me kathy chapman
can't believe
her 84 year old dad fell victim to a
sweepstake scam
it started with calls to his michigan
home in january she says
from someone who claimed to be from
publishers clearinghouse
they told him he'd won money and more
just like the people in those familiar
ads
in his case 2.5 million dollars a brand
new bmw and gold medallions
all he had to do was pay some taxes and
fees
but after he withdrew thousands of
dollars at multiple locations
his credit union alerted police who
called his daughters
and when they asked him about it he said
i just have to
pay some taxes and fees and then i'm
going to get this big prize
and i said no dad that's not how it
works chapman discovered her dad had
been instructed by the scammers to mail
them
packages of cash in all he lost 72
thousand dollars i'm still really angry
he's done nothing to anybody you know
he's worked hard
his whole life and got taken advantage
of
this is huge organized crime business
and better business bureau investigator
steve baker says those scammers are
professionals
his report says those con artists often
talk to victims
every day building trusting
relationships they take careful notes of
the victim's family
and try to isolate them from family and
friends and they'll use any method they
can
sometimes it's through the u.s mail text
messages
emails social media like this fraudulent
email claiming to be from publishers
clearinghouse with photos of winners and
a message from the board chairman
but a closer look reveals clues like
typos for example how the company
pleases to advice its supposed winners
of their delivery and presentation date
chris irving with publishers
clearinghouse if your viewers get an
email a call any contact a letter that
says you won a prize but you have to
send money
rip up the letter hang up the phone and
report it to law enforcement
because that's a scam a scam chapman
says took
much of her father's life savings i want
to prevent this from happening to
somebody else you know just to tell
people
you need to be suspicious
well if you've lost money to a scam
report it to the better business bureau
the ftc
and your local law enforcement that will
help them track some of this down but
remember anthony
if somebody says you have to pay money
to win
it's a scam yeah as she said it just
doesn't work like that
anna thank you very much folks are
absolutely evil to do this